[Musik]
wir haben es bereits im Sommer 2021 in
einem früheren israelvideo angedeutet
König Bibi wird sich nicht so einfach
geschlagen geben sondern mit allen
Mitteln versuchen an die Macht
zurückzukehren und er hat es mal wieder
geschafft benjamine dann ja wo hat sein
Amt als Ministerpräsident Israels
zurückerobert nachdem seine Partei liegt
gut die Wahlen am 1 November 2020 mit
23,4 % der Stimme gewonnen hat die
zeitgleich der Partei ja ihrer Pizza
weniger als
[Musik]
18%. aber nur drei Monate später ist
Israel in Aufruhr hunderttausende
demonstrieren in den straßentelleries
der Präsident israel sieht die
verfassungsmäßige Ordnung vor dem
Zusammenbruch die Landeswährung kriegt
ein und Investoren haben die Flucht aus
dem einzigen noch demokratischen Land im
Nahen Osten angetreten was ist da also
los im starte Israel nun bereits die
Wahlen endeten merkwürdig sehr
merkwürdig sogar die Zusammensetzung der
Kresse des israelischen Parlaments hat
sich stark verändert die vielleicht
bemerkenswerteste Änderung war der
Aufstieg des parteienbündnisses
religisationismus bestehend aus
orthodoxen jüdischen Parteien mit extrem
rechten politischen Positionen wir haben
euch bereits in einem früheren Video
dass ich euch in der Beschreibung
verlinken werde erklärt wie orthodoxe
Juden auf gesellschaftliche religiöse
und jetzt auch politischer Ebene immer
mehr Präsenz zeigen und nicht nur das
die demografische Dynamik Leute darauf
hin dass diese sozio religiöse Gruppe in
Israel sehr schnell wachsen und mehr und
mehr Einfluss gewinnen wird und dieser
Wandel macht sich schon jetzt bemerkbar
die orthodoxen jüdischen Parteien haben
noch nie so viel politische Macht
erlangt wie bei den Wahlen von 2022
[Musik]
und die ihr inzwischen bestimmt schon
aus den Medien bekommen habt sind diese
extremistischen politischen
Gruppierungen auch an der neuen
Regierung oder netanjau geteilt aber
wisst ihr was den tanjao scheint kein
großes Problem damit zu haben der Mann
der als Architekt des modernen Israels
gilt hat es sich zum Ziel gesetzt erneut
das Ruder des Staates in die Hand zu
nehmen koste es was es wollen nach
langem Stillstand Fortschritte bei den
Koalitionsgesprächen zwischen den
tanjahu und nordrich die Gespräche mit
Modric von gegenseitigen
Entschuldigungen geprägt die religiösen
Zionisten behaupteten nicht eingehalten
unter die rechtsextrem Bündnis vor
überzogene Forderungen zu stellen das
waren jedoch nicht für alle gute
Nachrichten die Politik in Israel
brachte ein neues Phänomen praktisch ein
neues paradigmeier vor
[Musik]
gerade jetzt erleben wir den Aufbruch
der radikalsten und
traditionalistischsten Fraktionen des
Judentums bei den letzten Wahlen erhielt
allein schon das Bündnis religiöser
Zionismus 14 Sitze und mehr als eine
halbe Million Wählerstimmen das sind
fast 11% aller abgegebenen Stimmen ein
Ergebnis zu mal das mehr als doppelt so
hoch ist wie das von 2021 und sie zu
viertstärksten Fraktion im Land gemacht
hat es handelt sich um das beste
Ergebnis einer religiösen
nationalistischen Partei in der gesamten
Geschichte Israels im angesichts dieser
Zahlen fragt man sich was ist der Grund
für den Aufstieg der radikalen religiös
politischen Gruppierungen und was könnte
dieses neue Paradigma für Israel
bedeuten wieso sehen Experten die
Wirtschaft das bisher extrem
erfolgreichen Landes vor einem
beispiellosen Absturz all diese Fragen
und noch viele weitere werden wir in
diesem Video beantworten und zwar gleich
nach einer kleinen werbeeinlage unseres
tollen Sponsors Surfer den surfshark hat
nicht nur das heutige Video möglich
gemacht nein es hat auch ein VPN im
Angebot das ist wirklich empfehlenswert
ist vor allem es ist sicher und
vertrauenswürdig so laut ist zum
Beispiel selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindung starten mit natürlich kann
ein Virtual Private Network kurz VPN
einen nicht vor allen Gefahren schützen
die im Netz lauern man muss nach wie vor
Umsicht walten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hierfür eine Werkzeug
mit vielleicht mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert es in Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen im
Netz nach so verfolgen und Art zu hören
mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
Anonymität zum Beispiel mit dem
integrität ist alle unerwünschten
Cookies blockt weiter erforderlich ist
das hier so tun könnt als wärt ihr an
einem anderen Ort suchen z.B auf Website
und Internet
oder im Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sind
nur und blocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix
und anderes
anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internet fernsehen im Ausland
gucken willst du auf Shark kein Problem
aber das ist noch lange nicht alles denn
mit nur einem Server konnte könnt ihr
wirklich alle eure Endgeräte im
vpnalistieren Handys Notebooks oder
sogar euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt ihr
sonst noch auch noch ein Rabatt in Höhe
von 83% und deine ersten drei Monate
gratis dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also richtig los besorgt
euch gleichzeitig uns finanziell unter
die Arme das könnt ihr übrigens auch
direkt mit Hilfe des Spenden links den
ich euch ebenfalls in die Beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hättet
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun wieder schnell zurück ins Heilige
Land wo sich mal wieder extrem viel
Unheil zusammengebaut schnallt Euch also
gut an
[Musik]
die zweite Rechte
die Politik Israels verändert sich man
könnte sogar sagen dass sie sich mitten
in einem umbruchsprozess befindet und
natürlich sind nicht alle Umbrüche eine
Veränderung zum Besseren im Gegensatz zu
anderen Ländern hat das Aufkommen
radikaler Parteien in Israel nichts mit
Einwanderung einer Wirtschaftskrise oder
Korruption zu tun ja dann ja und seine
enge autorage haben noch immer Probleme
mit der Justiz aber das hat die Wähler
nur wenig davon abgeschreckt ihnen ihre
Stimme zu geben
es war weit von den Ergebnissen von vor
ein paar Jahren entfernt hat aber bei
einer höheren Wahlbeteiligung den
gleichen Prozentsatz an Stimmen erreicht
das heißt die absolute Zahl von Bibis
WLAN hat sich im Vergleich zu den Wahlen
2021 erhöht nein die korruptionsprobleme
der traditionellen Parteien erklären
also nicht warum die religiösen
Extremisten ihre Wahlergebnisse in nur
einem Jahr verdoppeln konnten
man könnte sogar sagen dass die
israelische Wirtschaft bisher wie
geschmiert läuft seit zwei Jahrzehnten
Verzeichnis Land ein solides
Wirtschaftswachstum die Arbeitslosigkeit
ist auf eine historischen Tiefstand und
der Technologiesektor boomt weiter
selbst die Inflation blieb in der Zeit
vor den wahlenden 5% auf eine
vergleichsweise niedrigen Niveau lief
also nicht aus dem Ruder wie in den
meisten anderen Industrieländern und
wenn es etwas gibt das Israel
charakterisiert da sind es strenge
Grenzkontrollen und dann allgemein hohe
Aufwand für die innere Sicherheit in
viele Anhänger rechter Parteien in
Europa in ihren Ländern vermissen
[Musik]
was jedoch in Israel feststellen können
ist eine wichtige politische Verwerfung
in der traditionellen rechten was der
vorherige Premierminister nach talibanew
2021 an die Macht kam schaffte er dies
indem ein sehr ungewöhnliches
politisches Bündnis bildete eine Art
frankenstein-koalition aus acht Parteien
die alle möglichen Ideologien umfasste
ein Bündnis das eigentlich nur von einem
einzigen gemeinsamen Ziel
zusammengehalten wurde benjamine dann
Yahoo von der Macht zu verdrängen dieser
ganzen äußerst kuriosen Geschichte haben
wir sogar ein eigenes Video gewidmet mit
dass ich euch verlinken werde damit ihr
es euch später ansehen können ja wo war
damals auf dem Tiefpunkt seine Karriere
von der Macht verdrängt und zugleich in
mehrere Gerichtsverfahren wegen
angeblicher Korruption verwickelt
Verfahren die im übrigen nach und nach
zu seinen Gunsten entschieden worden
[Musik]
aber bereits im Jahr 2021 versuchte er
dann eine Regierung mit der RAM eine
arabischen Partei und mit den orthodoxen
Juden der religiösen zionistischen
Partei zu bilden der Anführer der
letzten Schloss jedoch die Möglichkeit
aus seit an seit mit einer arabischen
Partei zu regieren für ihn war dies ein
rotes Tuch und so kam es das nach
talibanet ein ehemaliger Verbündeter und
Staatschef von der US zum
Ministerpräsidenten schaffte das Problem
war nur dass er dies auf eine Art und
Weise teilt die für einen großen Teil
der israelischen Rechten gleich eine
doppelte darstellte er paktierte sowohl
mit den Rahmen Arabern als auch mit ja
ihrer Pizza Mitte Linkspartei jeschiert
[Applaus]
die nationalistische Rechte der National
Liberalismus die liberale Mitte die
zionistischen Sozialdemokraten wie grüne
Linke die Islamisten das antimethan
Bündnis brachte acht sehr
unterschiedliche Parteien und Bündnisse
aus dem gesamten politischen Spektrum
zusammen es war daher keine große
Überraschung das ist schon nach kurzer
Zeit auseinanderbrach ja 2021 verdrängen
Sie Natalia auch von der Macht aber kaum
ein Jahr später verbracht das Bündnis in
1000 Stücke und zwar die Israelis
verärgerten die erneut zu den Ohren zu
gehen und zu allem Überfluss fühlte sich
ein großer Teil der rechten Wähler durch
die Teilnehmer an dieser
frankenstein-koalition verraten
genau aus diesem Grund ist netanjas
Unterstützung bei den Wahlen 2022 zwar
bescheiden aber einigermaßen zur Lidl
geblieben während sich der andere Teil
der traditionelle richten Wählerschaft
der sich weigerte Ernährung zu wählen um
orientiert hat wir reden hier von
Rechten Wählern die Bibi vor allem für
tupac-matisch und zu tyrannisch halten
das Ergebnis nun plötzlich hatten die
wieder das rechten flüges noch zwei
Alternativen sich der Stimme zu
enthalten oder für die orthodox
religiösen Parteien zustimmen und genau
das ist passiert und an dieser Stelle
taucht eine Frage auf die für das Land
auf lange Sicht sehr wichtig sein könnte
was könnte das enorme Wachstum so
radikaler Parteien bedienen in Bündnis
religiöser Zionismus bedeuten was genau
will dieses Bündnis erreichen könnte
dieser politische Paradigmenwechsel
einige der wichtigsten Errungenschaften
die Israel im letzten Jahrzehnten
erreicht hat so nicht machen aufgepasst
denn genau das werden wir jetzt unter
die Lupe nehmen
Hochspannung
netanjah aus Rückkehr ist mit
erheblichen politischen Risiken
verbunden man könnte sogar sagen dass
ich zu einem Schub der Destabilisierung
für ein Land werden könnte in dem die
politische Instabilität sogar das
berühmte Chaos der italienischen Politik
zu übertreffen droht seit 2015 ist es
Bibi nicht gelungen an den Wahlurnen
breite Mehrheiten zusammenzubringen
seither musste er sich zwischen immer
weniger logischen kohärenten und immer
radikaleren Bündnissen und
Vereinbarungen bewegen um an der Macht
zu bleiben auf der anderen Seite ist
netanjas politische Bilanz natürlich
voller großer Erfolge für Israel doch
diese nun angebrochene Phase könnte ganz
anders verlaufen und sie alle zu Nichte
machen sich auch ein Bündnis wie das das
religiösen Zionismus zu verlassen
beginnt schon jetzt böse nach hinten
loszugehen Haus Entscheidungen könnten
sogar dazu führen dass Israels größter
diplomatische erfolgreich seit
Jahrzehnten zu Nichte gemacht wird ihr
glaubt mir nicht dann seht euch mal das
folgende an der Außenminister der
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate waren vor
der Bildung einer rechtsextremen
Regierung in Israel aber warum
eigentlich erregt diese Gruppe so viel
Misstrauen was meinen wir damit wenn wir
sagen dass es sich um eine radikale
Gruppierung handelt
nun vor den Wahlen haben sie versucht
sich als etwas gemäßigter darzustellen
um mehr Stimmen zu gewinnen aber ihr
werdet sehen ihre Position ist
grundsätzlich schon seit Jahren klar und
daran hat sich auch nichts Wesentliches
geändert ihr müsst euch nur mal die
Worte ihrer wichtigsten Vertreter
anhören eine der beiden Parteien welche
die Kollektionen der religiösen
Zionisten bilden ist zum Beispiel die
nur haben eine Partei deren
Hauptanliegen vor allem darin besteht
die rechte und die Sichtbarkeit von LGBT
in Israel zu beenden alles im Namen der
Familienwerte versteht sich die üblichen
Ausreden eben neu aufgestiegener Anti
lgbt-abgeordneter sagt er wollte die
Jerusalem Parade verbieten Norm Chef
abimaus sucht nach einem Weg die
jährliche Parade zu verbieten die er für
anstößlich hält er deutete auch an dass
er versuchen würde das Verbot der
sogenannten konversionstherapie durch
das Gesundheitsministerium aufzuheben
das psychologische Beratung für
diejenigen die nicht schwul sein wollen
erlaubt natürlich ist auch der
koalitionsführer selbst kein
unbeschriebenes Blatt
Richard zum Beispiel den Marsch der
Tiere organisiert einen schwulen ein
bisschen Marsch der die Pride parades
verhöhnen sollte dabei wurden Esel und
Ziegen vorgeführt denn so die
Organisatoren und ich zitiere wörtlich
wenigstens begehend Tiere keine Sünde
tja hätte es Modric doch etwas mehr
Biologieunterricht statt Thora Studium
genommen dann wüsste er dass
gleichgeschlechtlicher Sex auch im
Tierreich ganz normal und durch die
Wissenschaftler mittlerweile 450 Arten
dokumentiert ist von der Fruchtfliege
bis zum Elefanten und natürlich zählen
auch Esel und Ziegen dazu wobei bis zu
10 % der Bürger schwul sind aber mal im
Ernst wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
Israel der einzige Ort im Nahen Osten
ist an dem überhaupt große Pride Parade
in völliger Freiheit abgehalten werden
können und das einzige Land in dem
gleichgeschlechtliche Paare nicht offen
verfolgt oder damit Hinrichtung bedroht
werden und nun haben wir es in diesem
eigentlichen Liberalen Land mit
politischen Informationen zu tun zu
deren Spitzen funktionieren
Persönlichkeiten wie immer Ben Gewürze
erzählen ein Mann der Mitglied der
faschistischen karpartei war einer
Organisation die vom Staat Israel selbst
als terroristische Vereinigung
eingestuft und 1994 verboten wurde
tatsächlich Linden sogar die israelity
Fans forces also die israelische Armee
Band wird wegen seiner früheren
Mitgliedschaft diese Organisation als
Rekruten ab
[Musik]
ne tanjao hat zwar inzwischen alle
homophoben Äußerungen seiner
Koalitionspartner geübte um sich gegen
Diskriminierungen der LGBTs unter seiner
Regierung verwahrt an seinen
Koalitionspartnern hält aber dennoch
fest um an der Macht zu bleiben ein
weiteres wichtiges Thema für die
religiösen Zionisten ist natürlich dass
der palästinensischen Araber das Bündnis
ist absolut gegen die Errichtung eines
arabisch palästinensischen Staates und
stattdessen für den Bau von immer mehr
Siedlungen und sogar für eine Aktion des
gesamten Westjordanlandes und wir legen
eine andere Alternative auf den Tisch
einen Plan der nicht auf der Teilung des
Landes passiert sondern auf seiner
Vereinigung ich möchte die israelische
Souveränität über ganz Judäa und Samaria
besser als Modric Vorsitzende der Partei
der religiösen Zionisten natürlich würde
eine solche Annexion den Einsatz von
Gewalt erfordern aber damit entscheiden
Sie auch kein großes Problem zu haben
sie könnten nicht deutlicher sein wenn
wir die eiserne Faust zeigen wird es
keine palästinensischen Kinder mehr
geben die Steine werfen keiner wird mehr
Steine werfen denn was werde ich
anderenfalls tun entweder ich erschieße
ihn oder ich spreche ihn ein besseres
Modric vorsitzende die Partei der
religiösen Zionisten dieser politische
Führer befürwortet sogar Dinge wie die
Trennung von jüdischen und arabischen
Müttern auch Entbindungen Stationen von
Krankenhäusern und er erklärte
öffentlich dass er niemals zum Vergnügen
ins Ausland reisen würden
[Musik]
gut letzteres ist er eine Anekdote aber
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt sind all
diese Dinge eine Gefahr für Israel nicht
zuletzt weil sie die allmählich
einsetzende Normalisierung der Beziehung
zu den arabischen Ländern gefährdet und
diese ist nun mal die wichtigste
Voraussetzung für eine Chance auf
Frieden im Nahen Osten das Problem dabei
diesen Parteien ist die vollkommen egal
immerhin haben sie dann den letzten
Wahlen in den Siedlungen 22% der Stimme
bekommen das ist mehr als das Doppelte
ihre stimmenanteils im Rest des Landes
einige ihrer bekannten Vertreter sind
sogar dafür die Alexa Moschee in der
Altstadt von Jerusalem eine der
heiligsten Städten des Islam abzureißen
oder zumindest ihren Status zu ändern
und ist überrascht nicht dass diese
Partei auch ein kompliziertes Verhältnis
zu Frauen hat die sich nicht ihren
Ehemann unterwerfen zum Beispiel wollen
sie keine Frauen im Militär und sie
argumentieren das JournalistInnen die im
Fernsehen auftreten ihr habe Decken
sollten nun und genau solche
Gruppierungen hat mir dann ja auch nun
mit an die Macht gebracht Netanya Hose
ist extremistischen homophoben Politiker
als Verantwortlichen für Israels
jüdische Identität ein der designierte
Ministerpräsident unterzeichnet eine
Koalitionsvereinbarung mit abimaus der
radikale Ansichten über das nicht
orthodoxe Judentum LGBT Israelis Araber
und Frauen vertritt damit wir uns nicht
falsch verstehen bibi hat Israel in der
Vergangenheit zum Besseren verändert und
sehr viel erreicht doch wie weit ist er
jetzt bereits zu gehen nur um im Amt zu
bleiben und nicht ins Gefängnis zu gehen
[Musik]
für ihn scheint es jedenfalls kein
Hindernis zu sein radikale in die
Regierung zu bringen die den Liberalen
Werten des modernen Israels die
nathanjau selbst gefördert hat zu wieder
laufen und vergesst nicht dass wir über
Israel sprechen eine Oase in Bezug auf
Bürgerrechte und westliche Freiheit im
Nahen Osten während der
Koalitionsverhandlungen ist ist immer
partiell gelungen die radikalsten
Forderungen der anderen Parteien
einzulegen insbesondere eine
Justizreform hat er ihn versprechen
müssen diese sieht unter anderem vor
dass eine Mehrheit im Parlament Gesetze
verabschieden können soll auch wenn sie
nach Ansicht des höchsten Gerichts gegen
das Grundgesetz verstoßen aber dazu
gleich mehr viele gehen auf die Straße
um gegen diese Reformen aber zum
Beispiel auch gegen die Homophobie in
der Regierung zu protestieren und
zunehmend kritisieren diese Proteste
nicht nur einzelne Entscheidungen der
neuen Regierung sondern die Regierung
als ganze ist aber nicht nur die
Zivilgesellschaft wendet sich gegen die
Haltung der neuen Regierung sucht den
diesmal Minister und vielleicht
wichtigsten Koalitionspartner die Reden
nachdem das Oberste Gericht in wegen
seiner kriminellen Vergangenheit für
ungeeignet befunden hatte überhaupt ein
öffentliches zuführen doch die lässt
sich nicht unterkriegen er zieht in
seinem Ministerien weiterhin aus dem
Hintergrund die Fäden und ignoriert das
Urteil des Obersten Gerichtshofs ja für
dieses gab bewusst in die Erde und König
Bibi sieht im Ganzen nicht nur günstig
zu sondern spinnt dabei ein weit
übergeordnetes Machtspiel es ist
sozusagen das Endgame zwischen
Judikative und Legislative im Staate
Israel
[Musik]
zunächst reichte die Regierungskoalition
in der Knesset Anfang Februar einen
Gesetzesentwurf zur Wiedereinsetzung als
Minister durch Entmachtung des Obersten
Gerichts ein dieses Gesetz sieht vor
eines der Grundgesetze Israel zu ändern
indem er den Obersten Gerichtshof die
Befugnis entzieht Ernennungen von
Ministern zu überprüfen und rückgängig
zu machen doch netanjah aus Bestrebungen
die seiner Meinung nach zu linkslastige
Justiz Decke unterzuordnen haben Israel
in eine wahre politische die
gesellschaftliche Krise gestürzt das
ganze Land ist in Aufruhr Woche für
Woche haben sich Hunderttausende
versammelt um gegen die
Gesetzesvorschläge der Regierung zu
protestieren sogar US-Präsidentschaft
bei geschaltete sich ein oder machte die
israelische Regierung dass eine
unabhängige Justiz eine wesentliches
Element einer Demokratie sein und das
ein Konsens der einzige Weg sei um einen
systemischen Wandel herbeizuführen
Israel Staatspräsident Isa Herzog sieht
den staatgah am Rande des
verfassungsrechtlichen und sozialen
Zusammenbruchs wer alle haben das Gefühl
das wird kurz vor einem zusammenpreis
stehen sogar vor einem gewalttätigen
Zusammenstoß das Pulverfass ist kurz
davor zu explodieren und wer prahlte
aufeinander nun mal wieder die zwei oben
erwähnten so zu ökonomischen Gruppen die
aufstrebende religiöse aber weniger
wohlhabende meist aus dem Nahen Osten
stammende Bevölkerung Israels mit den
besser gebildeten einkommensstarken
überwiegend aschken Nase schon und erst
sekulären Bürgern des Landes als
aschkenasien werden die Juden bezeichnet
die aus Mittel Nord- und Osteuropa
stammen sie dienen im Militär und haben
Tel Aviv in eine Weltmetropole
verwandelt die niemals schläft sie
tragen auch fast die ganze Steuerlast
und haben dazu beigetragen Israel zu
einem modernen Startup Nation zu machen
eine bevorzugten Ziele für ausländische
Investitionen das Problem dabei es lohnt
sich in Israel durchaus auch eine
reguläre arbeitsverpfeifen und sich
dafür von und ganz im orthodoxen
Judentum zu widmen die orthodoxen Thora
Studenten werden dafür vom Staat mit
übrigens Sozialleistungen belohnt ohne
sich wie die anderen weltlichen
Normalsterblichen in der hatten
Arbeitswelt durchschlagen zu müssen der
durchschnittliche säkulare
haushaltszeiten 9 mal mehr
Einkommensteuer als die ultraschallboxen
sage und schreibe 90% aller ein am
steuersozialversicherungs- und
Krankenversicherungsbeiträge stammen von
säkularen und nicht orthodoxen Juden bei
der Justizreform geht es also nicht nur
um geistige und geistliche Werte sondern
vor allem um sehr viel Taster
die staatlichen Leistungen für
ultraorthodoxer die mittlerweile 13% der
9,3 Millionen Einwohner Israels
ausmachen sollen nämlich noch mal
drastisch erhöht werden erstens durch
üppige Zuschläge für kinderreiche
Familien und zweitens für das talmut und
religionsrechtsstudium ein einer
hierüber eine weiteres er anekdotisches
aber umso mehr symbolträchtiges Beispiel
ultra-orthodox erhalten normalerweise
keine Hunde deshalb haben ihre Vertreter
vorgeschlagen die Hundesteuer zu erhöhen
aber dies ist nur ein Tropfen der das
fast zum Überlaufen bringt
säkulare ist Zahlen sechsmal mehr
Steuern als ultra unter dies zeigt eine
Regierungsbericht der scheidende
Ministerpräsident ja ihrer Pitt hat die
säkulare Öffentlichkeit dazu aufgerufen
aufzuwachen die Mitglieder der Karibik
im Gemeinschaft leisteten nur 2% der
gesamten einkommensteuerzahlungen in den
letzten 10 Jahren sind die beiden
Ultraorthodoxen beste Fraktion zu tollen
verbindenden im Gegenzug genossen sie
einen Monopole auf mehrere Fragen die
Religion und Staat betraften sowie eine
werd Dienstbefreiung für ultraorthodoxe
Männer ihre Präsenz in der Tanja muss
Koalitionsregierungen gab ihnen die
Möglichkeit Finanzmittel an ihre
Institutionen zu leiten und die
Kontrolle der Regierung über die
Angelegenheiten ihrer Gemeinschaft zu
begrenzen die für die Finanzierung des
gottesfürchtigen Lebensstils ihre
orthodoxen Mitbürger Verantwortlichen
säkularen ökonomischen Leistungsträger
haben nun die Schnauze voll sie gehen
massenweise auf die Barrikaden und
streiken gegen die Pläne tanjaos den
religiösen Teil der Bevölkerung
dauerhaft die alleinige Macht im Staate
und noch mehr Privilegien zu sichern ihr
Protest richtet sich gegen die nackte
Herrschaft von Mehrheitsverhältnissen
denn es ist ganz klar dass die Kinder
reichen orthodoxen die Zeit und die
Demographie auf ihrer Seite haben
schließlich musste jedoch wie überall
auch in Israel gelten Demographie ist
nicht gleich Demokratie sie ist nicht
die Diktatur der Mehrheit allgemeine
frei und geheime Wahlen sind nur einer
ihrer notwendigen aber keineswegs
einzeln hinreichenden Bausteine erst
ihre weiteren Elemente die
Gewaltenteilung Pluralismus das Recht
auf freie Meinungsäußerung
Minderheitenschutz und weitere
garantierte Grundrechte machen eine
vollständige und gesunde Demokratie Hund
und eines darf man nicht vergessen is
ist nur deswegen so reich und mächtig
weil es eben die einzige richtige
Demokratie im Nahen Osten ist eine Oase
der Freiheit in einer Wüste von Tyrannei
die damit einhergehende Rechtssicherheit
emanzipations- und Innovationsfreude
haben viele Milliarden an Investitionen
ins Land gelockt und die Israelis
wohlhabend gemacht doch nun scheinen die
Finanzmärkte vor BBC justizentfernung
wahrlich zu bippern die Investoren
ziehen sich zurück der Schenkel hat
gegenüber dem Dollar an Boden verloren
und die Zinssätze sind gestiegen nachdem
auch Lauren Summers der ehemalige US
Finanzminister von einer abrupten
Umstrukturierung des Rechtssystems des
Landes Abrieb
Summers Israel riskiert die
wirtschaftsbeschädigen wenn es die
Justizreform unterstützt viele Menschen
darunter auch viele die ihr Geld aus dem
Land bringen könnten haben das Gefühl
dass eine zu schnelle und nicht
sorgfältig durchgeführte Justizreform
ernsthaft und die greifende Fragen zu
Recht Staatlichkeit aufwerfen könnte
wird Israel also zu einem weiteren
negativen Beispiel dafür wie ein
wirtschaftlich erfolgreiches Land durch
eine einseitige und leistungsfeindliche
Politik in den Abgrund geritten werden
kann nun einige Israelis befürchten dies
und versuchen unterdessen ihr Geld im
Ausland zu bunkern womit sie den
Beispiel mehrere Tech-Unternehmen folgen
die dem Land den Rücken bereits geklärt
haben eine gefährliche Abwärtsspirale
droht sich in Gang zu setzen das Problem
die Wähler und die politische Basis der
Nationen haben mit Wohlstand Einbußen
für die gesamte Bevölkerung kein Problem
solange damit eine Stärkung ihrer Werte
und Normen eine hergeht und sie selbst
dadurch finanziell besser gestellt
werden wie in vielen anderen
Gesellschaften zeigt sich das gerade
jene die eigentlich am meisten von der
Solidarität anderer Leben am wenigsten
solidarisch sind im Gegenteil weil die
Verschmelzung von Blut Boden und
Religion übt einen starken Reiz auf sie
aus damit einhergeht eine Kultur der
Unfreiheit der Beschränkungen und
Verbote ein Beispiel ist vor wenigen
Tagen wollte der vorbestraftete deri
Frauen mit gebetsschals verbieten an der
Klagemauer zu beten und obwohl er dann
Yahoo auch hier den Vorstoß sofort
wieder verwandt war die Botschaft
unmissverständlich ein öffentliches
Abweichen von orthodoxen jüdischen
Normen wird nicht geduldet
[Musik]
so sieht das momentan die politische
Landschaft in Israel aus einem der
wirtschaftlich erfolgreichsten Länder
der letzten Jahrzehnte in dem jetzt viel
auf dem Spiel steht daher werden wir
genau beobachten wie sich die Ereignisse
entwickeln und euch schon bald mit Folge
Videos zum hebräischen Staat auf dem
Laufenden halten nicht zuletzt auch im
Hinblick auf die Haltung Israels
gegenüber der Ukraine und Russlands ein
Thema dessen Komplexität wahrlich ein
eigenes Video erfordert vergesst also
bitte nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen weiß
ich schon geschehen um es nicht zu
verpassen ja es kommen sicherlich
Ungewissheiten auf Israel zu und wer
weiß ob wir nicht schon bald wieso oft
Neuwahlen sehen werden aber bis dahin
seid ihr erstmal an der Reihe meint ihr
nicht sollte einen Schlussstrich ziehen
und Platz für eine neue Führung der
gemäßigten rechten machen haltet ihr es
für vernünftig solche radikalen Gruppen
in die Regierung zu holen nur um die
eigene Karriere um jeden Preis
vorzusetzen wie immer sind wir auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und die vielleicht
auch dabei gelernt habt falls ja gebt
uns bitte ein Like und teilt es auch mit
euren Freunden damit diese auch was
lernen natürlich Freunde unserer Zeit
gespendet von euch mit der EOS hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung für
den Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]